In the name of the Father and of the Son and of the Holy Spirit, Amen.
The reading from the Sinaxanion from A fifth, on which we commemorate the Holy New
martyr Ephrem, the newly revealed.
Nothing was known about this holy higher martyr until the 3rd of January 1950.
The date on which he revealed the place in which he was buried, in the ancient monastery
of the Annunciation, on the mountain of the Immaculate Ones, Amomii, at Neamakri in Atika.
From 1965 to the present day, the saint has appeared many times to the nuns in the monastery
or to pilgrims, both in sleep and in waking sight, surrounded by a great light and a sweet fragrance.
At these times, he has told him with details striking in their agreement of his life
and the circumstances of his martyrdom.
Saint Ephrem became a monk at the age of 14 in the same monastery which flourished from
that time.
After 27 years of ascetic life, he was taken by the Turks who beheaded all the other monks
and destroyed the monastery, and from the 14th of September 1425 to the 5th of May 1426,
he was subject to great torture.
Finally, the barbarians hanged him head downwards on a mulberry tree, nailing his feet and head
to the tree, and then cast his body into the fire.
Since this revelation, the saint has never ceased to show through a great number of appearances
and healings that he is alive in God.
He shows himself as an ascetic with an emaciated face or in his sacerdotal vestments, declaring
his identity and saying, I am called Ephrem.
He heals some of incurable diseases, reconfirms the irresolute faith of others, saves from danger
and fire, or can soles those who are in affliction, revealing to them the sufferings that he himself
endured for the love of Christ.
In 1982, Saint Ephrem appeared to one of the faithful, together with a holy hieromarter
Raphael of Michelini, who had also recently revealed himself in very similar circumstances.
The Lord seems to desire thus to reveal in a prophetic way that today, as yesterday, he
delights in his saints and pours forth his grace through them for the upbuilding of the
church and for the consolation of the faithful.
Through the prayers of our Holy Father's, O Lord Jesus Christ our God, have mercy on us
and save us.